her information and to talk directly
with authors during our live programs
twitter.com slash book tv
joining us now on book tv is aaron
arvidlen
her new book open secret the global
banking conspiracy that swindled
investors out of billions
miss arvidlen
conspiracy
i would argue absolutely
um
this is a story of how
bankers were rigging one of the main
interest rates that we all use
even the federal reserve has come out
and said that libor the london interbank
offered rate
shouldn't underpin our mortgages our
student loans our credit cards because
it was ripe for abuse and during the
financial crisis
that's when it all came out
turned out there were about
30 or 40 different traders around the
world
emailing texting saying push the rate up
push the rate down
and the ordinary consumer pays
so that's
to my mind that's the definition of a
conspiracy
who were these 30 to 40
traders and what kind of power did they
have to do this party in many cases the
traitors were very junior
one of them a guy by the name of tom
hayes is a british guy he's going on
trial starting early next year
he did very well he made a 5 million
bonus one year for rigging interest
rates
and he was well compensated and what i'm
hoping is in the trials of some of these
guys it will come out who above them was
ordering them to do this
what was his motivation
his motivation was his bottom line
his bonus
five million dollar bonus
not too shabby
in one year and this is being repeated
at banks all over uh deutsche bank jp
morgan um
[Music]
barclays rbs bravo bank so
it was happening to the tune of
trillions of dollars
how did the consumers suffer
in two ways
one if you're a borrower
and your bank was pushing down your
interest rate
it was good for you right if you're
borrowing money to buy a house
you're paying lower interest rates why
is it hurting well i'll tell you why
because
uh
if you're if you're
trying to earn income say in your money
market fund
or let's say they push the rate up one
one day because it helps their bottom
line then
you're paying more on your student loan
or your credit card
it affected
millions of consumers
and um even the federal reserve now is
saying we've got to get rid of this we
got to find something else
you're a
finance writer a financial writer is
open secret
written for people on the layman level
absolutely i wrote this
so that my mom could read it
and but it's also for you know wall
street types
but i like to be able to write books
that i myself would understand
and i don't i don't like to use jargon
and i also enjoy explaining complicated
topics in a way that everybody can
understand and we are all borrowers and
we are all lenders
and we should know that the interest
rate that we were using the libor
was a fiction
and it needs to be fixed and also that
this scandal actually broke open some
other scandals like the foreign exchange
scandal
the fixing of precious metals so it's
kind of shined a really great spotlight
on what's been going on
how is it that libor came to be the
standard
great question why in the world did we
use this british interest rate um it was
partly because
remember when the real estate market
started to boom and everyone was buying
and selling mortgages on wall street
they needed a one interest rate that
everybody around the world could use
and it was set by gentlemen's agreement
if you can believe that
the same way that gold and silver are
set and
the same way that some foreign exchange
rates were set as we're now finding out
so that's kind of how it became embedded
in our system
title open secret
the title we chose was because
the secret that interest rates were
being rigged
was open among the professionals the
wall street traders who were making
money off of this and their bosses
but we
the public had no idea
so it was their secret um and now it's
out in the open
there been a legislative or regulatory
response
to the liber crisis
one of the main characters in the book
was gary gensler
the former former head of the cftc
who had left goldman sachs and decided
he would really
try and
go after the wall street folks
his old friends in fact and
the white house didn't like that
and i detailed that in the book kind of
how he tried to really crack down on
interest rate rigging
and
ultimately did not win a second term
now it's really up to the fed they have
actually just yesterday called a meeting
of all the wall street banks
to say we got to come up with something
else we need a true interest rate that
reflects reality
so it's happening
the book is open secrets the author is
aaron arvidlen
now on book tv hugh howard exam